it's still broken but i'm doing well for
these actors
their roles nearly cost them their lives
which actor was chained inside a water
tank and a stunt gone wrong
how about the actor who suffered
terrible injuries as a result of some
wet metal stairs
from stunts gone wrong to total freak
accidents
all these close calls will have you
rethinking the risks that actors take
uh it was horrible it's very scary thing
while filming mockingjay part one
lawrence lost her breath choking when a
fog machine malfunctioned and suddenly
started emitting
really dense smoke into the tunnel she
was filming in leaving her trapped and
struggling for air
once the team realized what was
happening they stopped and managed to
rescue her
after the incident lawrence struggled
with vertigo and nausea for a really
long time
and if we burn you burn with
us o'brien's injury was so bad the
shooting for the final film in the maze
runner series was stalled for almost a
full
year after suffering critical injuries
when a stunt went very wrong
as a result of being hit during a stun
o'brien broke almost the entire right
side of his face
suffered brain trauma and a concussion
since that accident o'brien has said
that he's
really anxious approaching stunts and is
super thorough when it comes to checking
the safety of all the equipment
the stunt didn't end up being for
nothing though since a shot from the
fateful day
actually made the final cut of the film
uh we're all affected by that you know
that was a very scary
situation you know isla fisher is an
amazing actress but
unfortunately she was a bit too good
while shooting a scene chained inside
a giant tank full of water so good that
the crew didn't even realize fisher was
actually stuck and drowning in front of
everyone
fortunately a stuntman noticed she was
struggling and stepped in to help break
her free while fischer went for the
quick release switch
horrifying and i was banging and saying
you know set me free but everyone just
thought i was doing fabulous acting
this was a very freaky case of right
place right time
aaron paul had asked the director if he
could move to a different spot in the
scene they were shooting for whatever
reason
lucky he did since a giant boulder was
blown off the top of an rv
and landed exactly where he'd just been
standing before
considering all the stunts and effects
in breaking bad it's pretty shocking
that this totally random freak accident
was what wound up being such a close
call for paul
yes hell yeah when filming with animals
there are always risks and while depp
was shooting lone ranger
things got intensely close to tragedy
the actor fell off a galloping horse
while filming and was dragged for almost
30 yards all the while trying to avoid
being literally trampled on by the huge
animal
it was a miracle when he walked away
with only a giant bruise in the shape of
a hoof print on his stomach
not many people are as lucky as def was
to walk away from that alive
the director gore verbinski even said
that it was one of the scariest moments
he'd ever witnessed in his life
i love you you have trouble with it if
you ever thought metal stairs couldn't
be that dangerous in the rain
guess again jamie alexander experienced
a terrifying accident when she slipped
and fell all the way down a middle
staircase while filming
the actress displaced a disc in her
spine chipped 11 of her vertebrae
dislocated her shoulder and tore the
rhomboid on her left side
she had to take a month off from filming
to recover and even when she was back
she took
everything really slowly to make sure
she didn't aggravate the injuries or
worse
injure herself all over again the only
thing i would probably be nervous to do
is an underwater stunt because i'm not a
strong swimmer
let's start with the fact that tatum was
already in quite the predicament
wearing a wetsuit and walking in a
freezing cold river
in order to prevent hypothermia the crew
was mixing cold and boiling water
together to get a nice
temperate water to pour into his wetsuit
between takes
just one time the crew member forgot to
mix in the cold water
so tatum had scalding hot water poured
and trapped inside of his suit
it was so bad some of the skin on his
legs actually
burnt off tatum immediately began
hyperventilating and screaming and even
jumped into the hypothermic water to try
and get some relief
this is so ridiculous watching the
sinking of the titanic is intense
but what's worse is that while they were
shooting it got
way too real for winslet who actually
got caught and nearly drowned
while shooting a scene of her running
down the hall with water flooding behind
her
her jacket got caught and she was
trapped desperate for air and swallowing
water
she wound up suffering influenza heavy
bruising and even a chipped bone as a
result
winslet was so traumatized that when
asked if she would do the film all over
again
she's never confirmed since it was so
horrifying
it's i can still feel it now the beloved
summer holder had way too close a call
during one of his fight sequences
and his poor co-star nathaniel bazalic
felt extremely guilty about it since he
was responsible for the mistake that
could have cost us one of our favorite
actors
bazaalis predicted it could have been so
bad that the accident would have ended
his career
eventually he's going to start using a
little more common sense
she looked tough as the snake haired
medusa and percy jackson but
behind the scenes thurman was shook to
the core after a terrifying freak
incident while on set a crew member
forgot to put the brakes on a van and
the vehicle wound up moving and hurtled
towards a totally unexpected thurman
luckily pierce brosnan pulled the
perfect 07 move
and jumped in front of the van to stop
it from running thurman over
moulin rouge was not an easy project for
kidman
first she broke her rib after falling
off a trapeze which took her out of work
for a full two weeks
when she returned her rib was
refractured by
a corset pulled way too tight at least
she won multiple awards including a
golden globe for all of that pain and
suffering
and the winner is
[Applause]
nicole kidman
stunts gone wrong are never fun and
charlie's theron learned that the hard
way
the actress wound up herniating a disc
and was just one centimeter away from
being paralyzed for the rest of her life
after attempting a handspring backflip
in platform shoes
after only six weeks of doing physical
therapy muscle relaxers and
three hours of physio every day she
finally returned to filming
the difficulty didn't stop there though
she suffered nerve damage and spasms for
eight years
she realized afterwards that she really
had to be prepared for anything
good boys cruz has had
way too many close calls but edge of
tomorrow was definitely one of the worst
he and emily blunt were shooting a car
stunt and had done so once successfully
blonde was instructed to do it again
only faster
in the car blunt recalls crews ordering
her to hit the brakes but by the time
she did
it was way too late and they ended up
crashing straight into a tree
you need to get us off this beach the
cast that pit has on his arm during the
movie
is very real and it came as the result
of a stunt gone wrong
pitt was jumping across moving cars
covered in rain and
unsurprisingly slipped on one and a
windshield broke his fall
or rather he broke the windshield and
sliced a tendon in his arm
since the film was shot out of sequence
the scenes that took place before pitt's
character fell and injured himself in
the movie
all had to be done strategically to hide
the fact that he was already in a cast
i'm good cause i'm about ready to punch
you another terrifying car incident for
uma thurman
but this time she was the one behind the
wheel
director quentin tarantino had pressured
thurman into doing the stunt even though
she wasn't totally comfortable
it turns out the seat wasn't screwed
down properly and the road itself was
far less straight and safe than thurman
had been told so it's not a surprise to
learn that she crashed right into a tree
thurman thought she'd never walk again
as she waited to be rescued from the car
she suffered damaged kneecaps a neck
injury a giant bump on her head and a
concussion
only years later did she see this
footage from that fateful day
well we're definitely freaked out
who knew that some of these roles
carried such danger with them
we're shocked by how quickly some of
these actors managed to even recover and
get back on set to shoot
which close call did you find most
shocking